she seems quite
graphic and distressed
[Music]
the scenario we're testing out at the
moment is a holographic form of a
patient with aspar
and
as you see behind us the student is
treating the asthmatic patient
and if he treats it in the appropriate
way the patient will improve
if he doesn't
treat him the appropriate way the
patient would deteriorate
[Music]
throughout medical school we had you
know acting patients come in to do
particular clinical scenarios then we
had vr simulation which is kind of like
this but it does not actually use the
real space it's just a screen in front
of your eyes this kind of takes it to
the next level where you actually mix
your real world and holographic patient
there and you kind of get the visceral
haptic feedback of you know treating a
patient in real life
[Music]
i think that what we're doing and what
other companies in mixed reality are
doing is a wonderful expression of where
the metaverse really truly makes sense
[Music]
you